last week we start doing something a
little bit different on the Dave Ramsey
show each week we're going to pull my
daughter Rachel Cruise in with me here
on the show for a segment or two and
talk to parents talk to aunts talk to
uncles and grandparents about how we can
all make sure that the next generation
is raised as MoneySmart kids one of our
sayings we've had for a long time if you
don't teach your kids how to handle
money they will end up living in your
basement at 30 playing Nintendo so you
got to teach them and so Rachel's here
with me now and today we're going to
talk about teaching your kids about work
yeah that was a Ramsey kid thing yeah we
might not have taught you nothing else
but we did teach it to work no doubt
about that so what uh you know I never I
read never really asked you I just kind
of told you so I'll stop and ask you
this time oh you're so sweet what really
helped you what really helped you
understand the importance of work I've
got my theories as to what we impugned
upon you but but what really did work
what caused you to have the work ethic
that you've got well I would say from as
early as I can remember
we were working I mean this wasn't a
choice necessarily I mean it was just a
part of our lifestyle part of what we
but what we do as Ramsay's is you just
work and so that's that's how we grew up
and it wasn't really a discussion but
one great thing I think you guys did was
put us on commission versus allowance so
you work you get paid you don't work you
don't get paid and so learning that
early on I think was great now that I
have the association between work and
money money comes from work money
doesn't come from mom and dad's back
pocket and so implementing that I think
helped us a lot I can still see a little
Rachel or a little Daniel or a little
Denise in my mind where we almost made a
game of cleaning up the room when you're
four and the money really wasn't the
deal about it
but then we the money was like a bonus
it was almost like hey we get to do
something together
we're showing you how to do something
you get to clean your room and we you
know sing some stupid song we made up or
something while we're cleaning up the
room and the parents clean up most of
the room when they're for the kid cleans
up a little bit but the kid gets all the
credits and the attaboys and so we're
creating a you know a task orientation
here and then we would pay you like a
dollar for cleaning up your room and why
the dollar up and you know put it in a
clear jar or something like that yeah
Commission is a word I grew up with
because my mom and dad were in the real
estate business and of course Rachel
knows that and so I grew up in a
entrepreneurial straight commissioned
household so I would put the whole world
on straight Commission if I could and so
you know that's why I don't think we
need a minimum wage you work you get
paid you don't work you don't get paid
you work more and better and smarter you
get paid more and better and smarter I
mean it's pretty cool and that's how
life works really and so I don't like
this word allowance allowance sounds
like welfare to me and so um you know I
just don't I don't understand this it's
an entitlement kind of feeling and why
should a kid be giving money just
because they breathe and take up space
we take care of them we love them we
give them clothes and they have food
they have warm place to sleep and
they're cared for and they're nurtured
but this idea that I owe them money just
cuz they hung out um that sets them up
to be a really bad employee well I think
that's the key there is you're doing it
to benefit them in the long run you're
building this foundation for them so
they grasp this cause-and-effect
you know relationship if you will that
work equals money and so setting them up
there when they're 16 years old and have
a part-time job it's not shocking when
they're going off on their own
after college or after high school that
they're not getting whiplashed by the
world because they have this foundation
under them but they understand well if I
have to eat and buy food I need a job
yeah and you know what's weird is it
does go over into other areas it goes
past just the economic thing of it it's
um
I wanted my kid to be the kid and you
guys are and were that when you were at
someone else's home and having dinner
and you finished you stood up picked up
your plate and took it to the sink you
didn't think that the plate was
magically going to end up in the
dishwasher
because there was a magical mommy who
cared for everyone and no one did
anything except the mommy who was the
slave of the house you know I didn't
want you to be that kid and we've had
kids come to our home that were friends
of yours over the years growing up and
and you know Daniel had a friend home
just the other day with him and the guy
you know how can I help what can I do
and he picked up this and he did this he
picked up the you know we were lifting
something he was the first one there
grabbing the end of it and that kind of
thing that's the kid you want to turn
your kid into because that's that's how
they behave at work later and that leads
to promotions and being noticed and you
know they're the ones instead of going
how little can I do to get by in this
life what extra can I do to add value
and it comes down to something as simple
as good manners at someone else's home
is how it translates so it's pretty cool
pretty cool stuff I didn't want you guys
to to just think that allowance was what
it was going to be they have that
connection between work and money is a
big deal but I will say I'll add in this
for the listeners as well is there's a
balance to this for sure I mean you guys
did treat us to things I mean you guys
were not that it was not a boot camp for
kids and money it wasn't this black or
white thing you guys had really a good
balance and I think one great thing you
know a line that we always say is too
many rules is legalistic but too much
grace is enabling and so I thank you
guys there was enough teachable moments
enough opportunities for us to fall and
make mistakes and learn the lessons of
hard work and and money and all of that
but it was not a crazy strict household
in that sense I feel like that you guys
did have a great balance over that was
our goal I mean because the idea is to
teach you not to punish you and not to
create little robots yes and I've met
parents like that when I travel and
speak you know I'll have a parrot come
up and tell me this kind of crazy story
and I'm like oh no you missed it like
your heart was good in it you know your
intention was good but it was kind of
way over the line for a five-year-old so
yes yeah there is a balance yeah you
really do and so what you want to do is
you want to provide a safety net after
you know a kid has worked really really
hard they've done some things and they
miss it by this much sometimes you step
in and you cover this much sure
but other times you let them suffer the
natural consequences of mathematics
there's not enough or better than that
even though it would be the natural
consequences of them not quite bringing
it they didn't bring their a-game and
the natural consequences is you don't
get to buy the item to join the money
and so you know you learn this idea that
money is finite and that you must you
know there is limits you can't just have
everything you want just because you
want it in other words the access of the
world doesn't run through the top of
your head and so my daughter Rachel
Cruise is joining me for a couple
segments as we talk about how to teach
your child about the subject of work
we've just finished this new book smart
money smart kids it will come out in
April and we will start the pre-sale on
it here in a couple of weeks we're going
to give you a bunch of goodies if you
want to pre buy it so go ahead and kind
of get yourself set aside and think hey
I want this thing and if you buy it
early we're going to load you up and
make you happy you did and that kind of
thing so you know this is a top of mine
subject how to teach the next generation
to be money smart kids it's right top of
mind for both of us right now and we'll
let you know more about the details on
the book and everything but it's it's
stuff Rachel speaking about a lot and
we're weaving into the legacy journey
series when we're out live all across
America by the way Boise sold out OKC
journey live sold out for Boise entre
leadership is still available but that
one's coming up here in a couple of
weeks and heading out there the first
week I believe of September RR September
of February and so forth and so I talked
about Rachel what what you can do with
recognition of a child's work in
addition to money how can you weave
those two together - and how did we do
it in your memory as you're growing up
recognizing that you can you know
recognizing a good job giving an attaboy
sometimes is more powerful than money
yeah I would say so for sure I mean just
the encouragement that you did something
because I think for the most part kids
that's not natural for them to want to
go and clean their room for instance and
so you know maybe having to direct them
that direction you know direct them that
way and
okay now this is what you're going to do
you need to clean your room and doing
something that they think that they but
they're not good at maybe something that
they think is impossible and that gosh I
just hate this but after they get
something complete I think to anyone no
matter what your age is when you
complete something there is a sense of
pride of wow I did this and then having
a parent come along and give them an
attaboy and say hey you did a great job
this looks so great I mean that just has
to boost the self-esteem of anyone no
matter what your age is cool stuff
Rachael Cruz we're talking about kids
and money and work for a segment or two
here this is the Dave Ramsey show
you